[Music]
in lifehacks news oh my god I love them
I like you but then I forget them me too
all the time I teach you guys today
clench your butt if you don't want to
cry I did it work but I want to cry do
it earlier I think my memories didn't
work
yeah it's cleansing I like crying mm-hmm
submitted by ila boba
I love boa - [ __ ] - I talk on
all the ship take like one sip at a time
sit westward and row at the same time I
had next one get out of here committed
to the brand you went too far yes you're
welcome you're welcome here are the
three stages of failure and how to fix
them there's three stages well here is a
necessary part of success yeah I don't
mind failing Wow I don't really see it
as a fail it's a lesson I'm like damn I
[ __ ] up but how can I fix these are
for people that give up or these are for
people that don't know when to give up
in my movie direction then redirect
themselves redirection alas that I don't
even know what fail means I can see if
like you'd failed the test like it
quantitative but I don't see like
failing at something alright so like
like a in life like career-wise yeah I
don't see that they're just lessons I
could see people failing at life though
being a [ __ ] loser you only feel if
you stop for me it's always been like a
work in progress you know I mean like if
I yeah how can you fail if you
completely if you're continuously trying
to learn yeah there's a book by John C
Maxwell called a failing forward and
it's like all about that and it's so
good sponsored by audible listen to
audibles - yeah but this video isn't but
we don't mind when it is alright so this
was originally posted on this blog by
James clear his career that's a cool
name let me be clear with you it's
better than foggy or dirty is bad
slurring James Dukey is it better than
just wash remember a decent story about
what did he do like on the phone he like
what call Dumas or something or done no
should call someone and he's like hey
mister [ __ ]
cuz it's pronounced she said why would
even pronounce it that way she said I
know you should change change so I
changed my last name my real last name
was limos narrow which means beggar of
money in Spanish really yeah the most
metal someone was a troll in the
Spaniard yes yeah the conquest of the
Philippines
it's like though people that look for
money for a church or whatever in church
we have that it's called le mana they
passed this basket put money in the
offering table thing the offering plate
in the Catholic churches you know how
yet Alfred that was a long stick and
they just pass it down
so James clear here he's saying that
there are three stages of failure so
stage one is failure of tactics ak8 how
mistakes what is that how a mistake like
you messed up in the way you did it yeah
so its failure to execute on a good plan
and a clear vision the way you fix stage
one is there's three steps to fixing
record your process so write things down
so you can measure oh and then the
second one is measure your outcomes so
if you're a weight lifter measure often
you train yeah and the third way is to
review and adjust your tactic so
successful people routinely give up on
tactics that don't move in their
strategy and vision forward so stage two
is failure of strategy aka what mistakes
so they occur when you follow strategy
that failed to deliver the results you
want you know why you do the things you
do and you know how to do the the work
but you choose the wrong what to make it
happen so three ways to fix it is launch
it quicker
I mean launch it quickly the faster you
test the strategy in the real world the
faster you get feedback on whether or
not it works do it cheaply so the more
time and money you invest into a
strategy the harder it is to give up
testing new strategies cheaply increase
the likelihood that you will follow the
strategy that works best rather than the
one you have invested in the most the
last way to fix it is revise it rapidly
strategies are meant to be reviewed and
adjusted if you if your original idea is
a failure and you feel like you're
constantly reviewing and adjusting cut
yourself a break changes changing your
strategy is normal that's dope the last
stage here is failure of vision the aka
why mistakes so they occur when you
don't set a clear direction for yourself
follow a vision that doesn't fulfill you
or otherwise fail to understand why you
do the things you do hmm
so three ways to fix it is take stock of
your life explore your core values and
review your recent experiences by
writing an annual review or doing an
integrity report oh cool - won't work
determine your non-negotiable so
determine what is the one thing that you
are not willing to budge on no matter
what
Anil I'm with you there grunts like you
guys have to do it no you know what I
don't know why it's so popular these
days it's just it is so you're not
supposed to do it it's it's kind of like
a it's like in every single porno now
like I'm just I'm why see everything
goes back to bottles yeah we talked
about Vimal as you know it it's a
butthole day it's a butthole Dave Rose
you brought it up I know I'm proud of it
Oh neat girl yes Queen people get
desensitized to the normal sex so that's
why they have to continuously like read
the the new norm on porn I did it that's
what the guy wants he's and then like we
were having sex he's like huh choking
you just doesn't work anymore I have to
like smack you I'm like well it's gonna
get you know gonna get bloody
yeah bounce again [ __ ] crazy she
comes in with the black I should think
had the best
I almost died last night we're gonna
have to [ __ ] tire like we have sex
next to the defibrillator now oh I
wonder if you take like a sex break like
if you go on a like sex rehab yeah just
go like somewhere like jail time for
like people spell [ __ ] in jail
I know bouquet maybe that's a bad
example solitary confinement okay like
let's say you just you go to a [ __ ] yeah
I go to monastery no need to go refuses
he wants it his way cuz there's horny
monks out there this is what I'm trying
to avoid avoid the phone
avoid masturbation avoid everything
every kind of sexual sense that you can
get pleasure from that's what celibacy
is yeah can you control yourself wait
it's not celibacy you gotta be in a
place where you are forced to like a
boot camp Oh cuz you have no central
celibacy boot camp when you don't have
some no cuz you can't live your regular
day life because it's gonna it's gonna
tempt you and you gotta be snapped out
of reality you can't see the other sex
that's that that's the thing too you
can't get visual like I already don't
see the other side be my own zone you
lost all of us control yourself
guys if I'm watching Netflix and I
haven't jacked off for a long time and
something happens it's shaped like a
nipple Twitter's trend right like
so-and-so days about
yeah I saw one leg back hearing but you
nibble or there's this one aging I was
like day five thousand whatever without
sex I'm not drinking as much both as I
can because I want balls in my mouth hey
I gotta go back to my [ __ ] point okay
so whatever it is the celibate is busy
[ __ ] challenge right yeah let's say
you [ __ ] go on this six month break
yep do you think you will be sensitised
back again and you're fresh like you go
back because I feel like in life I've
gone back and forth like too much and
then you don't care you come back and
you don't get eighty and then you're
just like [ __ ] thirsty know the
balance yeah I get angry when I haven't
had sex in a long time and I don't even
realize it's because of that thank you
snapping at Steve for no reason and then
I'm like but then I don't want it cuz
I'm Matt because I'm but yeah I'm like
did you see the Snow Leopard yeah yeah
planet Earth okay there's a planet Earth
episode where they got snow leopards
mating and the females basically in heat
and so she's like I'm horny i'm horny
and so all the males can hear her from a
mile away and they come in and she's
like i'm horny but she has a kid with
her so she's like I don't want the the
male to kill the kid cuz that's what
happens when they like mate they're like
they want their bloodline to go on or
whatever and so she's like I'm horny get
away from me I'm a Hornet get away
that's me that's awesome how did you
know that so she was referring to I
think I've told her that story before
yeah that was amazing cuz we just get
each other dia Bob over there
whatever guy misinterprets that what if
a guy goes all my girlfriend's mad at me
she must be horny and then he does it
with her and then he gets in trouble
because that was that's why you have
good communication no means no Joe when
I was when I was in a relationship my
limit is three days if I don't have sex
in three days I get noticeably angrier
mm-hmm Wow it's all when you're in a
relationship when I'm outside of a
relationship I can go wherever I can go
six weeks outside of a relationship oh
really
six weeks and I want to [ __ ] everyone
that walks by you time in a while it's
like you've been in a cave in your life
bushy legs elderly marriage walking
buddies like at the windows theory
you're like hey how old are you does
your dick work and the old man takes six
weeks [ __ ] again every six weeks I
use like this [ __ ] to thirstier can you
imagine all the guys watching right now
like hey uh have you had sex in the last
five weeks do you know why she's single
yeah it's true I'm single
[Music]